[Music]
prince charles becomes king of england
following the death of his mother queen
elizabeth
well within minutes of buckingham palace
announcing the very sad news of the
queen's passing we had the first words
from the new king and confirmation from
buckingham palace that charles will
indeed be known as king charles iii
the new king mourns the late monarch in
a statement
quote the death of my beloved mother her
majesty the queen is a moment of the
greatest sadness for me and all members
of my family
we mourn profoundly the passing of a
cherished sovereign and a much-loved
mother i know her loss will be deeply
felt throughout the country the realms
and the commonwealth and by countless
people around the world the prince of
wales and camilla were over at dunfrey's
house i understand it is my
understanding that the prince of wales
was with the queen
while she passed away this is a family
in mourning now and of course
the queen was a mother a grandmother and
a great grandmother we understand from
buckingham palace that the new king
charles iii and the duchess of cornwall
now queen consort will stay at balmoral
tonight
they will travel to england tomorrow
where charles will address the nation
and give his first speech as king
charles iii
[Music]